[Music]
isn't that part of the problem that we
have now with the old fashioned politics
Richard that many of the radical ideas
and Pat's the ones that catch more
headlines particular places like this
tend to be on the left whether it's
about the green new deal or whether it's
about changing the way that we engage
with the environment but a lot of those
radical ideas in terms of
transformational ideas are actually
emerging on the right wing of politics
too how does what you've described as a
social democratic Labour Party
incorporate engage with argue with but
but knowledge the existence of those
sorts of radical ideas - well I think
we've got to be clear about our values
and I do think actually that people have
always I'm always worrying when a
politician says let me be clear you've
got your right to worry you're right to
be worried let me be clear you're
correct to worry about that but I I
think people have always voted in terms
of their vision of a better society the
Labour Party has always been associated
with a fairer society for example Liz
mentions one of the dreadful things at
1945 Labour government did it also did
create the National Health Service
against Tory defend the 1947 Town and
Country Planning I want to defend that
Labour government for creating the
National Health Service in the teeth of
Tory option which actually is a great
example of socialist principles put into
practice a great example of something
being run not for private profit but for
public good and it we can learn about
that in other areas but to go back to
the question does that water water
transports energy these things can be
run for the public good as well so let's
take that principle of the NHS and make
it more wide but in terms of your
question about the ideas from there
right Vince said that we shouldn't freak
out about the advance of the far rides I
am freaked out about the advance of the
far right I'm freaked out that there's a
possibility that when the votes are
counted tomorrow and on Monday the
person who has a stage name of Tommy
Robinson could be elected to be a member
of the European Parliament representing
the Northwest so I think the challenge
for the left is not to be complacent but
to challenge the
ideas of scapegoating migrants because
one we look at the economic situation
the difference between left and the
right is who you blame for it do you
blame the economic system which had
delivered more inequality and the
greater concentration and wealth at the
top the system or do you blame migrants
people in receipts of Social Security
people who were disabled people so I
think there's a clear moral choice there
and when the far-right gets a hold in
our politics actually pulls the center
of gravity of politics even in the
mainstream to the right and in relation
to my own part they have to say that's
why under a previous leader Jeremy
Corbyn when they look with those mugs
that said controls on immigration which
I was deeply uncomfortable with because
actually they spoke to a wider unwelcome
discourse and when you make concessions
that discourse it never ends well for
progressive political values for modder
bates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at AI TV
you